dubrovnik is often called croatia's most
beautiful city
the country's most popular tourist
destination the port on the adriatic sea
has some 40 000 residents its
magnificent buildings bear witness to
the city's long history which dates back
to the 3rd century a.d
in 1979 unesco declared dubrovnik's
entire old city district a world
cultural heritage site
the city has inspired artists for
centuries like maya kovachevich who was
born here
the browning is special because it has a
strong bond between the history and
culture
when you pass the narrow street you can
see the different architecture from
different period
you can see the lots of different
foreigners coming here and by that
lots of different cultures are meeting
together
you can get a good overview of dubrovnik
by taking a walk along the almost two
kilometer long city wall
up to 25 meters high it's dotted with
defensive towers and forts
most of these fortifications were built
in the 14th century
back then dubrovnik controlled trade in
the adriatic
an elevated walk around the old city
wall is well worthwhile
people should come on the city walls
because they can see the
different
dublin from a different angle i like to
see the hidden gardens
which you cannot see when you're walking
down the street
i like to see the red roofs which is
also the one of the theme of my
paintings
the stradun is the main street in the
old city
after an earthquake destroyed parts of
dubrovnik in 1667
those areas were rebuilt in a unified
barak style
one of the most important buildings in
dubrovnik is the rector's palace built
in gothic and renaissance styles in the
15th century
it used to be the seat of the city
government
another late gothic and renaissance
building is the neighboring sponsa
palace where merchants once gathered to
do business
right next to the city wall is the
franciscan monastery striking colonnades
surround the cloister garden here the
monks grew herbs that they made into
medicines in the cloister pharmacy
there's been a pharmacy here in the
franciscan monastery since the 14th
century
what's special about it is that from the
beginning it wasn't just for the monks
it wasn't just for the city's rulers
it was for all of dubrovnik
zerch citizens rises on the outskirts of
the old city
you can reach its 400 meter summit on a
one-hour hike
or in just a few minutes with the cable
car
off the city's coast is the island of
lokrum monks settled here as early as
the 10th century
i like to come here to the walk
because
the colors are beautiful
i find the difference between the colors
of the red roofs of the old town and the
blue water and the sky
and after a day spent exploring
dubrovnik what better place to relax and
enjoy the view of the old city than
banya beach